i'm going to answer a question that i
get in some form or another quite often
this one is well worded and it's from
chris p
who is in a few of the private facebook
groups where i do
testing of various types here's the
question how does tim
integrate creating artistic flow in
parentheses
being productive getting done in
parentheses
self-reflection healing and
transcendence and then in parentheses
going beyond oneself be it spiritually
contributing to others etc in his full
life the crux of the question
is what he's learned on living a full
life and how he's learned to allow it
all
in given that we have the same 24 hours
in a day and 365 days in a year
and each of these endeavors could be
all-consuming of one's time and
attention maybe it's balance maybe it's
selective focus
maybe it's something very different i'd
appreciate his view so the question is
how you incorporate
these different facets
or pieces of the pie chart into your
life
i do not have a perfect answer i don't
think anyone has a perfect answer but i
can tell you
what i have changed in terms of how i
think about this and how i implement it
that has
helped me to trend in the right
direction where i feel better i feel
more holistically integrated so to speak
so let's look at this we have the
creative
let's call that artistic flow the
productive getting things done then we
have the self-reflection slash healing
slash
transcendence going beyond oneself
whether spiritually
contributing to others or otherwise
my experience is that you will never
find balance so let that sink in
that might sound pessimistic the reason
you won't find it
is because you have to schedule it if
you want any
semblance of covering these bases
in your day-to-day week-to-week
month-to-month life
in my personal experience it has to be
calendared and scheduled in advance i'll
give you a few examples of what this
looks like
for me let's talk about being productive
getting [ __ ] done
i block out mondays this is a monday
when we're recording right now just to
give you an example
where i will batch certain types of
activities that could be recording
videos
it could be phone calls with my team i
do one-on-ones with my team members
my employees administrative work is
batched
on mondays i do a lot of my say
podcast recording and audio on fridays
you'll notice that i'm not
trying to cover the artistic the
productive the transcendent
that in one day i used to do that and
the task
switching cost the channel switching
cost
is extremely high for me personally it
doesn't work very well there's a lot of
grinding the gears trying to move
between those things therefore
i block out days of the week where i'm
getting [ __ ] done
there are also going to be certain check
boxes that need to be checked off
right now i have one blog post per week
that must be published
that then gets blocked out in the
calendar for writing time
typically before noon or before lunch
on a given day that will be my focus
for creating before managing right so
create before you manage is a blog post
that i recently put up on tim.log if you
want to check it out that was reasonably
popular
and those are all pre-scheduled those
are a few examples on a weekly basis
being productive
on a quarterly basis i also have a
content creation week
where i will answer various questions
produce certain types of audio focus on
writing etc
get a lot done that can then be
distributed over the next
quarter the next three months that is a
quarterly example
of getting things done on the artistic
side
when i am home here in austin
i will almost always try to have at
least one day per week and it doesn't
vary so this could be
say a tuesday for a series of four to
eight weeks
or it could be on a wednesday doesn't
really matter but the consistency is
what matters i'll have a 90 minute
drawing lesson first thing in the
morning this is pre-input
before any type of email or anything
that might
distract me i'll sit down with an art
teacher
and work on say whether it's charcoal
pencil paint you name it
for graphic expression right that is
pre-scheduled pre-committed on the
calendar
then we have the transcendent the
self-healing
the reflective or introspective
i will generally speaking at least once
a quarter
schedule one to two weeks semi to
completely off grid this will be in
nature and i'm allowed to write but i'm
not allowed to read
and this could coincide with fasting it
often does but not always
and this will be time that is blocked
out once again
in advance and preferably pre-paid for
so whether there's travel involved
lodging involved
facilitators involved who could be say
breath workers they could be
experts in some type of therapeutic
modality like ifs or otherwise
having these things booked on the
calendar so that there is
a sunk cost fallacy that you can use to
your advantage
and you've already prepaid hopefully
irreversibly for these things therefore
there's a penalty for canceling and you
can use
the very exaggerated human tendency of
loss aversion
to work to your benefit in this type of
example
so this may seem like a very
sterile answer to a comprehensive
big question but for me it is a very
practical
answer and that is you have to put it in
the calendar if it's not in the calendar
it's not real you are not going to find
balance
you have to create it you have to
fight every lesser tendency that you
have in my case
that will stymie and self-sabotage
by putting into the calendar that is the
only way that i have found
to integrate these various pieces into
my life
and if i do not have them in my calendar
it's not going to work
things are going to break i'm going to
neglect important areas
and i'm going to pay the consequences as
a result so
that is a long way of saying get it in
the calendar pay for stuff in advance
commit to people so you have
accountability
and in my experience a lot of things
take care of themselves after that
you